[Applause]
thank you very much Hannah welcome to uh
all of you uh our live audience here for
intelligence squ also welcome to the
online audience watching the debate uh
via the intelligence squ website who
will doubtless be sending in their
questions later uh via Twitter this is
usually the David dimbleby moment where
he mentions things like hashtags Etc
that he clearly doesn't understand um
I'm not going to do that instead Let's
uh introduce our subject for tonight it
is uh look West nor East South America
will be the 21st Century's superpower if
the uh premise uh for this motion is
that Latin America uh does not get the
attention it deserves because people are
always looking elsewhere then I have to
say that uh not just myself but my own
newspaper I write for the guardian has a
little taste of how that must feel uh
right now some of you may have noticed
that while the Arab world and North
Africa are burning up with Revolution
and Military intervention and while
Japan is in turmoil after earthquake and
potential nuclear meltdown the guardian
has chosen to devote a month of coverage
to a season in Europe rather brilant and
so last week I was in Paris and
interviewing and then in Madrid
interviewing Diplomat or one Diplomat
after another and politician and each
one of them asked the same question as I
walked in which was you're a journalist
why on Earth are you here um so this is
perhaps Europe suddenly having a flavor
of perhaps what one half of this debate
may suggest Latin America experiences uh
often um I will also just uh plant to
have hovering in our minds uh again it
may be more seized on by one side of our
motion rather than the other uh the
Declaration from a grizzled and Veteran
editor of the New York Times who had
been taught through bitter experience
and said that Americans will do almost
anything for South America except read
about it and uh we may find some conts
to that uh proposal this evening so uh
that is the motion uh you will be
casting your vote at the end of the
evening by tearing your ticket in two
and voting with either the for or
against slip uh there if you are a don't
know then you should place the entire
ticket uh in The Ballot Box that counts
as an abstention uh and I also will be
giving you I know you've done a prevote
and I'll be giving you uh the result of
that after we've had the setpiece uh
speeches from our speakers um I'm glad
to say the format is and they will stick
very strictly to it that each speaker
has eight or nine minutes they'll speak
from the podium I will be quite Hardline
uh two minutes before I will give one uh
two strikes of the glass and one minute
before one strike of the glass and after
that I will gesticulate wildly and
generally embarrass you if you do not
come back away from the podium so that's
the procedure there will be then we'll
open it up as you all know people have
been here before uh to questions and
contributions from the floor and uh a
spirited debate at this end as well so
I'm going to introduce our speakers one
by one uh as they come up so our first
Speaker who may uh Ascend to the podium
is parag Khana who's a senior research
fellow in the American strategy program
at the new America foundation and is the
author of The wonderfully titled how to
run the world charting a course to the
next Renaissance and he is of course as
our first Speaker speaking for the
motion parag
KH good evening many of you are no doubt
here because you were seduced by the
image on the left side of this screen
this succulent seductive lady uh and you
might have hoped to see her or some
Avatar of her up on this stage this
evening instead of seven men sorry to
disappoint you that said she and what
she represents has seduced the president
of the United States for while we all
sit here this evening President Barack
Obama is in South America in Chile and
on route to Brazil
no doubt seeking comfort and Solace from
the world's turbulence what is his
mission he says it is to forge new
alliances across the Americas and he
will need them to counter those stiff
generals on the right side of this
program this evening now those generals
and the Chinese superpower that they
represent appear to be an unassailable
Force marching irreversibly towards
Global hemony but note that tonight's
proposition is not that China or Asia
represent the only superpower but that
South America will surprise us in
becoming one Now ladies and gentlemen
geopolitics is a very unsentimental
discipline it doesn't care how many
articles or books you've read about the
rise of China it doesn't care how much
money you've invested in Asian mutual
funds it doesn't care how many hours and
dollars you've spent on a Chinese Nanny
to Che teach your kids
Mandarin geopolitics is about the
relationship between power and space
thus tonight's debate should Center on
the elements of power where and how they
come together and how they are executed
nothing more it is already the case that
the 21st century is in fact multi-polar
and
multi-valent will emerge as the
superpower but there will be quite a few
that can claim that they are superpowers
indeed the combination of military
economic and diplomatic influence make
the United States the European Union and
China already superpowers their
influence extends around the world they
are the three largest imperial units
they're models which are actively
spreading themselves around the world
they have resources they have ambition
why is Latin America why has South
America so perennially been excluded
from this conversation about geopolitics
well there's a naive and simplistic
assumption that hegemonic power moves
and Cycles from east to west and now
East again ignoring the complex
realities of how power the power of each
depends on in some ways on the power of
others the second reason is that South
America has for so long been considered
a resource provider rather than a
resource
deployer and the third reason is that
the South American continent has been
considered geopolitically inert and
marginal and subservient especially to
the United States ladies and gentlemen
all of that has
changed First China is not not just
Rising by itself it is bringing others
with it Latin America's booming exports
to China are part of the reason why we
can have this debate this evening about
South America rising to the status of a
superpower according to Standard
Chartered Bank the trade between Latin
America and Asia is the fastest growing
of any interpair of regions in the world
and that trade is very balanced as well
so China is not uh so South America is
not being bought or owned in some
neocolonial pattern such as many
describe Africa today to the contrary
China's rise is elevating South America
and it will continue to grow and benefit
from that secondly in an age of resource
scarcity it matters who controls the
resources South America represents a
very sizable share of the Earth's total
bio capacity the Amazon rainforest is
the world's lungs and the continent is
also the world's Bread Basket producing
most of the world's bananas sugar Orange
es coffee soybeans and a major share of
the world's beef and pork it also has
massive mineral deposits silver copper
lead tin zinc iron ore lithium all of
these in this very rich continent the
Western hemisphere in fact as a whole is
on the cusp of energy and food
independence from the rest of the planet
Canada the United States Mexico
Venezuela and Brazil are all major oil
and gas producers for a hemisphere that
has only 1 billion people and those
resources are far less volatile than the
Middle East on which in fact China and
Asia depend in fact Brazil itself may
just have discovered as much oil as
Russia has and Canada is physically as
large as Russia except it
works so in a century of resource
scarcity supply has the upper hand on
demand third South America previously
had no leader but today Brazil has
emerged as a confident and mature
international power it is leading the
creation of a union of South American
nations it has become active with Europe
across Africa negotiating with Iran and
trading with China no one really knows
if China's economic figures are real but
ever more people are confident in the
Brazilian
Ral South America's economy as a whole
is already the same size as China's but
with only half the
population due to the success of Chile
and Brazil there is a new consensus
across South America that has taken hold
it reverses centuries of political
volatility in favor of a consistent
pattern of social democracy Pro poor
investment and a welcoming uh climate
for foreign direct investment South
America is at a state is in a state of
Peace there are no active hostilities
between its Nations it has relatively
few countries and a common cultural
heritage no doubt we look at South
America and we see Hugo
Chavez and his cantankerous Rule and he
has almost LED his nation into conflict
with several neighbors such as Colombia
but that is not materialized very
largely due to the mediation of powers
such as Brazil on the whole Brazil's
role has in fact been to animate Latin
American leaders to stand up for
themselves and be a part of this story
of South America's rise now like North
America South America's is
geographically isolated from
geopolitical threats much as America
Rose during a period of Splendid
isolation so too will South America by
contrast Asia is very turbulent the
great power rivalries and suspicions
that plague the region are alive and
well between China Japan India and South
Korea Asia is in fact leading the
world's arms bizar all countries around
China have dramatically increased their
acquisition of military assets uh to
hedge against China's rise can you be so
sure that China's commercial dominance
and the Asian culture of Defence will
prevail over parochial interests and the
and the the parochial interests of proud
Nations that are armed to the teeth I
wouldn't bet on it and leaving aside the
rational Powers there are still major
flash points in Asia from Myanmar to
North Korea Rogue regimes that could
suck Asia's Powers into military
conflict if World War III will take
place anywhere it will be in
Asia and China is not without domestic
disturbances from the waves of protest
against corruption at all levels to the
existential challenge of caring for its
vast elderly as its race to clean up the
environment continues without without
taxing the society to the limit when is
currently choking much of its population
by and large though this entire case can
be made without bashing Asia which is of
course the continent from which I come
despite my rugged Latin looks which
brings us back to Obama's trip for this
week in which he went South not East
America has realized
that South America is its TurnKey
solution to its two greatest challenges
energy security and economic
competitiveness Obama's trip takes place
on the 50th anniversary to the month of
the alliance for Progress which sparked
a very important wave of modernization
and industrialization in South America
in the 1960s today America is launching
a new alliance for progress in the
region American firms are relocating
from Asia towards to Mexico and other
Latin American countries while
Partnerships in energy and trade are
flourishing between America and Brazil
together North and South America will be
able to compete with
Asia and whose rise America has so
willingly sponsored through the
Outsourcing and Manufacturing is going
to come back to America's time zone in
other words South America will become a
major 21st century superpower also
because America wants it to be one the
rise of the East then will reunite the
West stronger than ever but this West
will include not only just the United
States and Europe but also a new third
pillar South America thank you very
much I hope the other speakers noticed
the mest flick on the glass and he was
back in his seat this is the rod of iron
which I propose to use this evening uh
our next speaker is himself a former
editor but one of the very few who
actually can claim to have covered uh
South America seriously in his
publication nevertheless despite that
he's here to argue against the motion
he's the former editor of The Economist
and author of Rivals how the power
struggle between China India and Japan
will shape our next decade here to argue
against the motion I suppose suggesting
that we should look East East rather
than West um is Bill
EMT well thank you very much uh chairman
and to intelligence squar for having me
here this evening and I'd like to thank
my friend parag kanana for making the
first uh Speech against the
motion his uh excellent uh Speech told
us exactly what I think which is that
the 21st century should not be a century
in we in which we look in One Direction
or the other it should not be a century
in which we choose China over Brazil
India over the United States it should
be we should hope it will be a century
in which there will not be a single
superpower in which there will be many
powers and perhaps a balance of those
powers of course looking to the future
we must remember always um the wise
words of uh Sam Goldwin that we should
never forecast especially about the
future we should look at the future with
humility anyone who uh looks at the
speed of movement of events in North
Africa and the Middle East since
December when the first Spark came in
Tunisia anyone who looks at the
potential impact on Japan of the
earthquake and tsunami and nuclear
disaster on March the
11th should be touched by that humility
by that sense
that any forecast about the future is
first of all something that of course
would rule journalists out of a job
since if it was all clear nobody would
need to buy our Publications or read our
columns or our books but secondly that
many things can and will
change but let
me emphasize how profoundly pessimistic
the motion actually is about that future
a motion that says South America will be
the 21st century superpower look West
not East that is profoundly pessimistic
because it assumes that the way we're
developing now which is to have the
greatest uh growth
in living standards
in human uh in Humanity's income in the
movement of people out of poverty that's
ever happened in history thanks
substantially to what's happening in the
most populous part of the world namely
Asia home to half the world's po
population 3 billion plus
people that this might come to an end
that this might achieve some sort of
terrible Den numon that in the future
this progress of the East might be
severely
interrupted now in my book as was kindly
marketed by our chairman um I do say
that there is rivalry between China
India and Japan that will help to shape
the
future but I do come from a background
in which I think that competition can be
a positive thing there are arms races
there is real tension in Asia There's
real tension within the countries of
Asia over future types of of government
that those countries should have
particularly in China the speed with
which the Chinese government and
authorities have sought to Snuff out any
signs of protest any signs of uh of
dissident uh emulating events in Egypt
Tunisia Libya and elsewhere shows how
paranoid they are about these
prospects but
still to see the 21st century as being
defined solely or chiefly by South
America requires a very pessimistic view
about the outcome of that story in Asia
not just that there'll be interruptions
it's not just that there will
be perhaps bits of instability as China
democratizes as India deals with its
inequality as issues such as the
unification of the careers are played
through no not just instabilities but
rather that this whole process will come
to some sort of a terrible
conclusion because
otherwise a steady growth in the half of
the world that we call the
East should produce very very powerful
countries in that part of the world that
would be at least a balance to very
powerful countries in the western half
of the
world I believe we should be very
positive about the prospects for South
America especially about Brazil of
course the dominant country of South
America the pr progess in the last 20
years in the politics of Brazil the
economic management of
Brazil the management of inequality
within that country the spread and
development of its democracy have been
spectacular and have been extremely
welcome and I hope very much that they
will
continue but we must recognize the
weaknesses also within that
continent Argentina is usually
one president away from its next default
it
is it is the world's champion sovereign
debt defaulter anyone looking for
worries about the Euro and future models
for how you how you do a sovereign debt
default always reach for the file marked
Argentina in their um in their file
Mexico the second uh great economy of
the region has the world's murder record
the crime in the Mexican border region
with drugs related crime is very sadly
absolutely
spectacular
Venezuela Hugo Chavez um is a notable
figure there of course and I am a proud
owner of um his
Constitution he came to the economist to
meet with some of us there and when we
started asking asking him about problems
with his Constitution he said yes it's a
excellent Constitution and reached into
his pocket and pulled out a little blue
book very like Ma's Little Red Book and
said look here it is I wrote it I'll
sign it for you and here's a
copy I have it on my bookshelves at
home so what I want to say about Latin
America about South America is that they
are not together a unified
nor um actually especially well
integrated region of the world they are
a region with great potential Brazil
especially I wish them extremely well
but I think we should recognize the
pessimistic view that the idea that they
will become the 21st century superpower
what this
represents the strength of Asia the
population of Asia the speed of change
in Asia the great flexibility of the as
Asian economies and Asian societies is I
think remarkable and
impressive we hope and we should hope
that the development of that part of the
world will spread and deepen and indeed
spread into greater
democracy we should also assume and hope
that the United States will be still the
21st Century's
superpower it goes through its ups and
downs it's currently in a bit more of a
Down than an up
but Winston Churchill's great uh comment
about America about the United States is
worth always remembering which is that
America always can be relied upon to do
the right thing once it has exhausted
the
Alternatives I will leave my colleagues
to talk about the merits of Europe and
of Britain but I do think you should
vote against the motion you should be
optimistic about the future a future
that is balanced between many strong
countries big and small that doesn't
follow the fashion that's been the
fashion for the last few years of
looking only for large countries to be
important in the world that perhaps
looks back at the Fashion prior to that
in which the nation state was supposedly
becoming less important and hopes that
in fact superpower status will become
much less important in the future and we
will have a much wider development a
much broader development and one must
hope a peaceful world as a resell thank
you ladies and
gentlemen thank you um there can be no
mistaking which side our next uh speaker
is on a senior lecturer in law at Burke
Beck college at the University of London
he is the author of relevantly for our
purposes the ambitiously titled what if
Latin America ruled the world our next
speaker for the motion is Oscar
Guardiola
Rivera may you leave in interesting
times goes the saying attributed to the
Chinese sounds like a good omen doesn't
it but I'm told they intended as a curse
looking at the most decisive events of
the century so far from the water wars
in Bolivia to an stolen election in
America the debacle of Iraq the Great
Recession or Civil War and Military
intervention in Libya It seems
impossible not to agree that we do live
interesting
times whether you look at the happy
non-democracies of the east or some of
our own unhappy democracies caught
between austerity and Gloom you may be
inclined to think that the Chinese got
it right that to use one of those
profound terms we philosophers are so
fond of we're
screwed so where can we look for much
needed hope and some inspiration I say
look West not East everyone knows
interesting things are happening in the
Americas I have written a book whole
book titled why if Latin America rule
the world which describes some of the
things that are happening there
as well as their historical context but
most important of all it explains why
there are good reasons to choose what I
call the happy democracies of the
Americas as an image of Hope and an
example to the rest of the
world for instance there is a strict
parallelism between the Grassroots
mobilizations we have been witnessing
recently in the Arab world and the
Grassroots mobilizations that took place
in South America during the first decade
of this century
in both cases the people stood up
against domestic as well as foreign
dictates and took it upon themselves to
realize the promise of Freedom held back
for so
long to the extent that Brazil and the
other countries of South America have
managed to enhance their capacities for
self-rule while deepening their
commitment to democratic and egalitarian
institutions dating back some 200 years
ago the continent as a whole has become
a beacon of freedom and hope around the
world the resistant nations of the
Western Hemisphere have Consolidated a
unified voice around such institutions
as mercosul unasur ipsa and other
successful instances of regional and
South South cooperation while at the
same time overcoming the situation of
dependence that characterized the period
after the L late
1990s crucially they have renounced
violence and War as the norm of
international and domestic IC relations
opting instead for a principle The Stand
in favor of equality and
democracy this new situation contrasts
sharply very sharply with instability
and non-democracy
elsewhere this is why as he T South
America US President Barack Obama was
able to hail Brazil or Chile as an
example everywhere in the world which
shows how to transform itself into a
viant democracy which shows that a
democracy provides freedom and
opportunities to the people as he put it
but this is also why Obama knew he could
not pretend the United States would ever
again deal with Latin America he had
done in the past in terms of dictates as
if South American countries were
America's
backyard you know interesting things are
happening when the president of the
Lonely superpower has to acknowledge
that realistically speaking the best he
can hope for is an equal partnership
between his country and the countries of
South America that in a way
America needs the countries South of the
Border more than they need the us
because among other things there is a
whole Latino Nation within the United
States which in demographic terms
already doubles the rest of the
population and will triple or quadruple
its presence in the US by
2050 hope didn't come to Latin America
we made it our own but hope in Latin
America is always tempered by sobriety
our optimism illuminated by a clear
memory of past failures and current
challenges some of our own making others
associated with a long and not too
distant history of colonialism
unfinished projects broken promises and
intervention also in this respect Latin
America's leadership matters we are less
confident than many of our euroamerican
counterparts in the inevitability of
multilateralism in the modern world this
may lead towards a more antagonistic IC
view towards a world order based on a
balance between five or six Powers
calling all the shots but also towards
more ambitious goals concerning our
regional and international entities this
has been exemplified in the position
taken by Latin America Visa the
international fin International
financial institutions earlier on and
more recently in the wake of the 2008
Global crisis in its calls for a
complete overhaul of the postwar
arrangement its leading role in the
negotiation that led to the Declaration
of the heran in May last year or in the
global partnership dialogue launched by
Brazil and the United States last
February in all of these cases the point
is the same to interact with the rest of
the world with America in particular as
sequels this is the thesis of my book
the combined power of the two Americas
brought ever closer by a common
libertarian history economic ties share
the space and demographics will give any
abstract Nation with pretentions of
hegemonia run for its money this is why
I believe you should look West not East
it is no surprised that in the last
Global survey conducted by the BBC World
Service in 27 countries around the world
the positive opinion about the influence
of countries such as Brazil has
increased from 40% to
49% while negative views fell 3 points
to
20% in contrast China's positive rates
fell six points this year to 39% with
40% rating it
negatively I have no intention to deny
the many achievements of the East
particularly in respect to the millions
of people who have been lifted out of
poverty in recent years or to demonize
it we should not fall for the false
dilemas or Us Versus Them manayan
choices rehashed by people unable to
understand that the world has moved
on these people lazily hang on to the
tire mantras of the threatening order
gloom and decline
declinist fail to acknowledge that no
one is seeking to replace the United
States that he has no real competitor
and that it will continue to play an
important military and cultural role in
the coming years alas from the so-called
rise of China or Brazil and the rest of
South America does not follow the
decline of the West just as the rise of
the West in the 15th century did not
follow solely from China's decision to
turn
inwards if there is any if there was any
decisive event Al those centuries ago it
was the encounter between peoples from a
Asia Africa Europe and the Americas we
leave with the consequences of that
encounter some were dire and we should
not deny them in the name of some
mystical idea of progress others still
unfolding Point towards the enhancement
of what is best about us all exclusively
peaceful relations with the rest of the
world a model that connects democracy
with inclusive growth employment
creation and international interaction
based on diplomatic Solutions perhaps
even some non-modern solutions to our
very modern problems cooperation to
reduce famine and poverty and to create
more democratic mechanisms to deal with
global questions these My Friends Are
Not Mere ideals this is Latin American
practice this is the reason why Latin
America has been hailed as an example to
the world and this is why you should
look West not
East but if you still need some
convincing let's make fun of Phil
philosophy once more as you know we
philosophers love engaging in very
complicated thought experiments so let
me try to conclude this evening
something much less sophisticated let's
call it a god- feeling experiment
inspired by the publicity for this
event look at these images and tell me
which way you would
go would you choose him
or
him or perhaps you might prefer him
would you go for these strong l ladies
or these strong
ladies or perhaps you would prefer
her who could blame you I won't I know
what I stand and I believe you know
which way your vote will go tonight
thank
you the diary story almost writes itself
about the all male panel assembled by
intelligence squ which ended up flashing
pictures of scantily clad women on the
screen I won't leak it if you won't um
our next speaker is like the first
against the motion a journalist also a
graduate of The Economist where he
reported from Brussels Bangkok and
Washington but not I notice from South
America uh he is now the chief Foreign
Affairs columnist of the financial times
where he's a mustre and the author of
Zero Sum Futures American power in an
Age of Anxiety here to oppose the motion
Gideon
[Applause]
rakman thank you very much Donathan and
thank you for inviting me ladies and
gentlemen Latin America is a great place
as you've just seen with those
spectacular visual aids I'm afraid I
don't have pictures of scantly clad
dancers or hatchet-faced Chinese
generals to entertain you with but what
I do want to do is to explain to you why
although Latin America is a very
positive optimistic place at the moment
there is no way that it will rule the
world or indeed be the superpower of the
21st century not politically not
economically and not even
intellectually now having ped a bit of
cold water on that let me start with
some kind kind of words let's start with
what's with what's going right I was I
was uh actually in Brazil last week so
never let it be said that I don't go the
extra mile to do my research for
intelligence Square debates um and like
like uh Jonathan I had the experience of
thinking you know I write about
International Affairs why am I actually
in Brazil rather than uh you know
somewhere a little bit more in the news
but then I noticed that Obama was also
in Brazil so I thought well obviously
I've got something right and you can
totally understand why people are paying
attention to the country and to the
continent and why people in Brazil are
so upbeat at the moment the economy is
growing strongly the Brazilian Finance
Minister has just claimed a little
prematurely that it is now the world's
fifth largest economy but even if it
isn't quite yet it soon will be unlike
in the west where we've had 30 years
marked by Rising inequality Brazil which
has been a by word for for inequality
actually is now seeing falling
inequality the Bola Familia this program
of social transfers is a highly
successful much admired social program
Brazil's commodity exports as parag
pointed out are booming foreign reserves
are high the currency is strong in fact
it's too strong they're complaining
bitterly about it rents and bankers
salaries if that's a sign of Health are
now higher in sou Paulo than in New York
the World Cup's coming the Olympics are
coming what could go wrong Brazil is
certainly fashionable it's part of the
most fashionable geopolitical
arrangement in the world the bricks
uh but unlike the other bricks it's not
scary it's not scary like China or scary
like Russia and it's certainly less
chaotic than India so Brazil is the
cuddly brick it's the one that everybody
likes and that they give all the
tournaments to now look look more
broadly at the continent again it's a
positive story growing fast countries
that were once famous for terrible
conflicts have often outgrown them Chile
successful prosperous democracy Peru's
beating The Shining path Colombia's
largely beaten the drugs cartels and
continent wide this is as has been said
a conflict free zone the wars that
disfigured Central America are over but
this will still not be the Latin
American Century let alone the Latin
American decade or whatever you want for
several reasons the first is simply
sheer size the total population of Latin
America is just shy of 600 million
that's less than half the population of
China alone and when it comes to
economic weight size does matter because
the Chinese economy at the moment is
just uh as somebody pointed out the size
of the the Latin American economy but
China is growing much faster than Latin
America China's been growing at an
average rate of 8 to 9% a year for the
last 30 years it may not be sustainable
for for the next 30 years probably won't
be but it's got a momentum behind it
that Latin America simply doesn't have
Brazil as as I where I was last week
they're they're growing at 7% but they
say not really sustainable probably 4 to
5% as our natural rate of growth maybe
that's more healthy but if China's with
one population the huge population is
growing at twice the rate of Brazil you
don't really need to to do the
mathematics to to work out what's what's
going to happen the the sheer economic
weight of Asia is just going to be much
much larger than that of Latin America
and China is not actually that anomalist
India is also growing at 8 to 9% a year
another country of over a billion people
so the sheer
economic weight of Asia is going to
completely dwarf that of Latin America
and political power does flow from
economic power it's not a complete
mathematical translation that this side
of this size of economy equals this
amount of political power but look at
the Pol growing political clout already
of China in the world I mean the
Brazilians are are are locked into an
economic relationship with China that
they're not entirely happy about because
they are the commodity supplier their
manufacturers all going out of business
because Chinese goods are out competing
them and certainly you know it's the
Chinese who are going around Europe
offering to buy up Greek bonds or fund
Portuguese debt not the
Brazilians so that's the economic side
but then I think one also has to look as
well as making this comparison with Asia
you have to look at Latin America which
although it has a lot going for it also
does still have many weaknesses
inequality is coming down but it's still
one of the most unequal parts of the
world the drug gangs may have been
beaten in Colombia but they're rampant
in Mexico where 28,000 people have died
since the Calderon Administration
launched its drug war a much higher
civilian toll than even in Afghanistan
and in fact the Mexicans will tell you
I'm not sure if it's true perhaps the
Brazilian Ambassador can put me right
but they will take you aside and say
actually the murder rates higher in
Brazil and it's higher in Central
America so this is quite a violent
continent education is another big
problem on the pasas of rankings of
school attainments in maths and literacy
Brazil comes very low down the ranking
and Brazil is half the continent it
became 53rd of 62 in in reading and
maths the US which thinks it has great
problems in those areas is in the 20s
Britain is in the 20s as well and if you
take the famous Shanghai rankings of the
world's top universities there isn't a
single Latin American University in the
top
100 finally ideology Oscar to judged by
his book and by his his uh speech
tonight believes that Latin America
represents in some ways a new slightly
more Humane form of globalization and a
new way of approaching economics but it
seems to me that a lot of the success of
modern Latin America has actually just
entailed an Embrace of the globalization
that we already have Lula's first trip
as president of Brazil was to the world
economic Forum in Davos the Festival of
globalization where all world leaders go
and pay court to the same investment
bankers and Multinational Executives and
if you go to the Latin American dinner
Davos it's stuffed with presidents there
who basically embraced the globalization
consensus the Latin American populist
left still romanticized by many in
Europe I'm afraid represents a dead end
for those who doubt it consider that
Hugo chavz was the 2009 winner of the
morar Gaddafi International prize for
human
[Applause]
rights that's not one that you want to
keep on your mantle
piece so Latin America is a great place
it's an exciting place it's an
optimistic place but it's certainly not
going to run the world and Latin
Americans frankly should be grateful for
that given the current travails of the
US running the world is not all it's
cracked up to
be later on Gideon perhaps you'll share
with us some of the previous winners of
the uh Mama Gaddafi prize for human
rights I think there may be some here
tonight some here tonight some resident
in this country perhaps even some former
Prime Ministers of this country I was
wondering so we'll have to hear from you
who the next uh who the previous winners
were our next speaker is an advocate for
South America not just for fun here this
evening but that is how he uh earns his
living He is a trained engineer but also
one of the most seasoned diplomats in
London representing the country hail as
the superpower of this uh region that
might indeed itself become the
superpower of the 21st Century
the country you just heard being
referred to as the cuddly brick uh the
ambassador of Brazil to London please
welcome our next speaker his Excellency
Roberto J
jibe good evening and thank you very
much it's a it's a pleasure to be here
of course uh the first thing to consider
is the fact that no no one can question
the fact that we are entering to a very
clear phase of multipolarization in the
world and that there will be no single
superpower we're going to have different
focuses of power and in fact superpower
is an acronym as a name or a category
that does not appropriately apply to
Latin America or to Brazil we do not
Aspire that we aspire to be in a in a
world of more equilibrium of more
Cooperative stances but this is a very
strong posture this is a posture that
has transformational elements in it and
which is required to improve the world
and I think looking to South America you
will find that we will have
contributions in order to generate the
type of dialogue and intervention that
is required to optimize the
possibilities of a more multilateral
multipolar scenario I think this is one
of the the important elements of of of
uh uh South America we are witnessing of
course course a major transformation I
think China is one of the countries
perhaps the country that has pushed for
that transformation and opened the doors
for others to become visible Brazil
amongst those South America amongst
those the major elements of
transformation that China have brought
has brought a very important among those
I would say that to become a very
important country it's no longer
necessary to be a developed country
China is a developing country will be a
developing country for a very long time
but it's a determining country in the
international scenario this applies to
very a number of other elements a number
of other countries that goes for India
as well it's certainly goes for South
America and for Brazil the advantage of
South America in relation to other
regions is that we are without any doubt
living in the most extensive cohesive
and homogeneous region of the world
there's no geographical space that is as
homogeneous as cohesive as Latin America
is because of its history because of its
problems because of its challenges
because of its population and the
language is also a common ground
everybody knows that Spanish is a
variation of
Portuguese we have enormous elements of
of of importance that contribute uh to
the fact that we can really place and
and have an important role in this place
in the world demography which has been
placed in St as a deficit for Latin
America is to a certain extent a deficit
I concur with that but let's say if
Brazil had the geogra the demographic
density of Bangladesh we would have 10
billion inhabitants in Brazil so
demography is also in a in a challenge
for growth democracy also presents an
enormous benefit to to to Latin America
we have two or three major issues of the
21st century which are clearly resolved
in South America and Latin America in
general which are environment energy and
water South America energy is is a is an
enormous Surplus we provide about 30% of
the world in in growing because the
prospects of additional uh fines in oil
in Brazil alone are already very
significant but it's not just Brazil
many other countries are beginning to
find very significant deposit of oil in
that
region renewable energy is fundamental
water
South America provides 30% of the
renewal water in the world water is a
scarce uh element in Asia it's going to
become even scarer and Latin America has
Brazil alone has 15% of all the
renewable water of the world this is a
fundamental element Commodities are not
just going ahead and producing something
because you have the land the space uh
or the air or the sun in as in
agriculture commodity requires an
agricultural production require
competitiveness require investment the
reason why Brazil and many other Latin
American countries have become so
competitive in commodity exports is
because of an enormous amount of
research that has gone into Agricultural
Development the Brad baskar of Brazil
today is the center center part of the
country which was cons considered
completely inept for agricultural
production uh until about 30 years ago
so it's not just a question of having uh
uh lack of capacity in research and
technology which is a problem I must
confess but it's the fact that we have
devoted enormous energies to the to uh
maximizing benefits that are structural
in our
region another very important element
relates to the cultural Dimension which
I already mentioned uh all of of Latin
America is very Diversified from the
point of view of the cultural formation
of each country we are a very syncretic
culture that is very much the case in
Brazil that brings m multiple cultural
references in play we have the ability
and this is not exclusive of South
America India to a certain extent has
the same benefit of being able to look
into things from different angles which
provides a much better possibility of
understanding amongst not just inside
but also uh in relation to uh
international relations in
general
uh we have been uh working very hard to
change the international scenario and we
believe that the the the format that is
really taking place and taking shape
today which is the multipolarity is
extremely beneficial to the type of
vision that we bring to this matter
which is essentially the idea that we
must have horizontal and not vertical
relations another element which we think
is fundamental and which provides a
certain novelty in this space is the
idea of doing away with the likeminded
country's agenda which has dominated
international relations for the past 20
50 years maybe after after after the the
second world war likeminded agenda has
not resolved the political even the the
the economic or the development issues
in the world we favor on the contrary a
diverse minded country uh uh uh
Coalition which will be able to provide
different perspectives to Common and
traditional problems that have not
actually been solved another element
which I think is important to consider
when you look at the 21st century is is
to create and to distinguish between
structural and conjunctural problems
Latin American South American in
particular does face and we do face
significant conjunctural limitations and
many of those have been mentioned there
are limitations in relation to education
there are limitations in relation to
infrastructure there are limitations in
relation to Science and Technology but
these are limitations that are
essentially conjunctural limitations and
not structural limitations what do I
qualify structural limitations long-term
impediments to continued growth
demography is one uh natural resources
is another availability of water and
others are continuous and also the the
the the the the the the the difficult uh
Geographic and uh geopolitical uh
environment as has been already stated
South America uh is very much at peace
it's a country that has a number of
minor irritants in in in in relation to
uh National questions but it's
essentially been resolved throughout the
19th century uh on the other hand we
also have an enormous degree in each
country of national uh integration this
is a crucial element in the definition
of what the nation is how many big
countries in the world do not have any
problem of national integration I will
tell you two United States and Brazil
all other countries of a big size have
enormous problems of national
integration which constitute significant
barriers and problems to their own
development most Latin American
countries present one difficult
challenge which is being superseded
which is social integration and this
again has been already qualified we do
have problems of social integration but
the advances in the policies that have
been carried out not just in Brazil but
throughout the region have placed Latin
America on the other hand of what is
taking place all around the world which
is growth with increasing income
distribution we have not witnessing that
anywhere else in the world be it the
developed World be it the other parts of
the underdeveloped developing World
growth with income distribution is a
characteristic that we will find today
only in South America and of course
there are other cultural Elements which
believe are very important uh we have a
very clear national identity in relation
to literature music uh and uh a very
general optimis Mystic you know in I am
not very favorable to the meth
methodology that is applied in many of
these surveys but one of those that came
out recently said that of the 10 most
optimistic countries in the world nine
were in South America in Latin
America and of course uh we I I just the
numbers are already very representative
today uh South America according to
figures of the IMF or the uh uh C a
already represents the fourth largest
economy in the world after NAFTA which
is the biggest Europe which is the
second and China which is the greater of
course we have a much lower population
than any other of these combinations but
we already are a very significant
economic power and in terms of
Commodities the numbers have already
been provided I could add a list to
those in which we are very
representative and finally of course we
must state that we have been for a long
time and hopefully will continue to be
the world's most important Powerhouse in
football thank
you saving the best to last perhaps uh
many of you will have heard our next
speaker on the radio as presenter of
radio 3's night waves also author of a
bitter re ution China's struggle with
the modern world he is the professor of
the history and politics of modern China
at Oxford our last speaker speaking
against the motion is r
m thank you uh Jonathan and everyone
here tonight I must say as Oscar was
speaking earlier on I thought that if
Latin America ruled the world one thing
that clearly would happen is that we
would all dress much better and clearly
the ties being Bor worn both by Gideon
rakon and myself would probably be
publicly burned as a crime against
fashion in that particular world so
perhaps it's lucky that we're not in
that world I want to describe the world
around us because I just came in
obviously uh to uh to London from from
from Oxford where I I live and as I was
traveling on the tube I noticed around
me an awful lot of people actually
studying and practicing the Portuguese
language and using a whole variety of
different little grammars and uh tapes
and iPods to practice those difficult
vowel and Continental sounds that the
Ambassador will know the kind of kuras
now and actually as I've been wandering
around the country I've been finding
this tremendous upsurge of enthusiasm
for the study of the Portuguese language
people basically realizing that as
Brazil takes its role as that great new
continental Regional power they need to
get in on the ground floor and start
learning the language well well that
would be a great idea except that as we
know that isn't really the world as we
see it if people are taking on a new
Global language the Stark reality is
that it is Mandarin that is the language
that people are taking on board whether
it's the nannies as parag mentioned it
or anyone else who's bringing it to
children but it is the Chinese language
that seems to have caught people's
imagination if you go around the world
and
Sayes you may get a pleasant smile but
if you go around saying you're going to
start actually doing business and I
think that reality that division between
the two is really where my part of
today's argument lies because I do want
to suggest that in the world order as it
is and we started with parag on the
other side talking about the reality of
global geopolitics rather than as we
might want it to be it's clear that in
terms of World Order and shaping of that
order it is the East and unashamedly I
will say that we're talking here about
the big Asian superpowers it is the East
that is going to shape the next century
and not to my regrets since the I'm as
attracted by this pictures as anyone
else the world of South America it is
going to be a place which is shaped very
much by a variety of new powers that
have something to say and have the clout
to make it happen and one argument that
I think put forward particularly by
parag that I need to need to uh to comat
immediately is the idea that the indias
the chin the Japan still the third world
world's biggest economy mustn't forget
about forget about it even it's
declining the idea that something called
an Asian culture of difference is going
to prevent these powers from really
having their say I think about prominent
Asian thinkers who have changed the
world ma sedong Mahatma Gandhi parag
none of these people none of these
people could be described in any ways as
inder to the way of thinking that the
world is is described by rather they are
people who have seized and changed the
world and it is with those figures that
I really have to make the core of my
argument now which is that with great
regret and great respect to our
colleague the Ambassador and others here
who hail from the uh continent of South
America in the end and for the moment
and for the time that I can foresee the
the global attraction of Latin America
is still going to be relative ly
globally limited as opposed to something
that I think is more universalizing on
the Asian side let's take the words that
um we talked about the cultural side of
things so let's talk about one of the
big transmitters of an Asian style of
culture around the world and that is the
Bollywood movie those of you who have
not yet enjoyed the pleasure of a 4-Hour
movie Extravaganza with singing dancing
and Incredibly um dubious plot lines
have a treat in store for them but it's
very clear that it's the B hwood movie
that has shaped cinema around the world
not the other way around if one goes to
Latin America the movie tunes from those
um uh from those Bollywood movies are
well known enough that people don't
actually know they come from India the
same is true in the Middle East the same
is true even in China this is a
universalizing cultural phenomenon that
comes from Asia if one looks at I don't
know how much of your time you spend
hanging out with 13 or 14 year olds and
I think I might uh uh lead to raised
eyebrows if I claimed that much of my
time was spent in that uh in in that way
at least not while people are watching
on the on the webstream but if you talk
to teenagers about the cultural impact
you will hear over and over again the
word manga in other words a Japanese
form also known as the anime which comes
from a very different cultural and
visual way of seeing that has gone
Global that has gone viral wherever you
go in the world and I'm sure that
includes Latin America the pictures the
culture the um the the visuality of the
manga and the anime are yet another
example of how a cultural meme a
formation from the Asian side has spread
across the world in contrast the things
that are uniquely and distinctively
culturally South American still I think
have a long way to go before they have
that wider transformative power I am for
instance a great fan of the 1960s
expressionist Argentinian film director
Leopold D Tor nilson I'm sure everyone
else on the panel is as well and we will
be swapping some anecdotes later about
his greatest uh greatest movies L Mano
tra Masterpiece on the other hand I
think it's fair to say and I made a
slightly unfair comparison there that
Latin American literature Cinema even
football where perhaps there a different
sort of cultural formation either tend
to attract um uh uh praise because of
the cultural specificity of what they do
or else because like football they are
something that is so globalized already
that there isn't necessarily anything
very Latin American um about them um if
we think about the way in which icons in
way the ways in which societies are
understood um are put forward let's
think about a figure like Mahatma Gandhi
if you're going to mention anyone who's
associated with um uh Progressive
political change in our own era perhaps
Nelson Mandela but perhaps across the
century Gandhi comes to mind more than
anyone else as a great Liberator Simon
bolard is also a figure of great
interest and importance who I I highly
respect but I think it's fair to say
that he doesn't get the instant name
brand recognition that a Gandhi has
around the world similarly if you go
around the world looking for cultural
symbols of that kind of cultural change
people may well point to the confucious
institutes who uh uh which um have been
set up in over a 100 countries around
the world to try and spread the study of
Mandarin I asked a friend of mine who
was here tonight um this evening if she
if I she had ever heard of confucious at
which point she pretty much you know
slapped me across the face for asking
such a stupid uh stupid question she
slaps me across the face quite a lot to
be uh to be fair I then asked her if she
had heard of Bernardo o Higgins you know
the great Chilean Liberator and I have
to say on that particular occasion she
clearly hadn't in other words there are
some
universalizable cultural tropes memes
ideas that I think are much more coming
from the Eastern than the western side
of our cultural universe and I fear that
that will be the case for some time to
uh to come the reason for this has been
touched on by some of the fellow
speakers on this side and so I won't
repeat where we've gone already but I
think it is the fact that the East and
particularly India China and Japan are
going to dominate the way in which the
next superpower has been formed is going
to be formed in the next century and
that is in Virtual space in cyers space
whatever we might like to believe the
reality is that Latin America is not at
the moment and is not in the near future
going to be dominant in the virtual
reality that will shape all the ways in
which we interact when the next version
of the IP addresses the Internet
Protocol is being discussed as it is is
right now those discussions are taking
place with Beijing they are not taking
place at the same level with Brazilia or
with buenos Ires and that's largely
because of the things that the
Ambassador himself acknowledged um in
other words that the educational level
the infrastructure the things that
absolutely make the formation of the
educational superpower of The Next
Century are happening in China they're
happening in India places like Ping
University the Indian Institutes of
Technology but not yet in Brazil
Argentina or the other countries of that
continent and in a country China where
even despite the authoritarian
restrictions on freedom of speech which
I suspect everyone in this uh room would
would frown upon there are 410 million
users of the internet growing daily
larger than the population of the entire
United States and they are creating a
new way of interaction that will shape
the nature of that next superpower so I
think in The Last Resort if we want to
think about the way in which the next
century is going to do log on to the
internet find out which is the language
that is being used most frequently aside
from English and actually coming up on
the outside and with great regret the
language is not Portuguese it's not even
Spanish it's Mandarin thank
you thank
you well thank you to r m and all our
speakers all of them admirably uh
concise I hope that will you'll regard
that as a model as we now open up the
debate you heard arguments on my right
here uh for the motion ranging from the
notion that the combined power of North
and South America will be uh awesome the
notion that the economy of South America
already matches that of China and the
argument that Spanish is a mere
variation of uh
Portuguese on my left against the motion
you heard the uh argument that uh the
region is with a heavy heart a byword
for uh debt murder and dictatorship uh
you also uh heard the suggestion that
size does matter and that the population
of South America is just too small for
uh superpower status and you heard the
call to look at the language people
around the world are learning and it
isn't Spanish or Portuguese so so those
are some of the spirited arguments made
uh just now before you heard those you
did vote and I'm going to give you the
result of that prevote it is the perfect
kind of result for a good debate evening
because the there were uh for the motion
236 votes those who did believe that we
should indeed uh look West nor East and
against the motion very finely balanced
279 but the reason why I say it's the
ideal uh result for an good evening is
that the very large number of don't
knows reached
2011 and it is those those 201 floating
voters that are six speakers will do
their best I'm sure to woo and persuade
this evening now is the chance for some
of those floating voters and others to
make their case uh let's get as many of
these in as we can let's see some hands
uh there will be people with microphones
who hopefully we can get to you well
there's somebody straight out of the
block there if yeah if you can go to the
gentleman there with the blue shirt I
will not discriminate against people up
there in the top so uh in the even more
expensive seats perhaps um so we'll go
with you first any other hand
that are coming up well let's hear our
first speaker um I would love to believe
in M guad Rivera's future of of Humane
Social Democratic Hegman in Latin
America but one thing that hasn't been
addressed so far I think is the 60 years
History of the United States
intervention in Latin America supporting
sometimes overtly sometimes
covertly uh tyranny um tyrannical
regimes in defense of its own interests
and we're not going to have Obama
forever we might well have a very
right-wing very reactionary president
next and perhaps for some time to come
we're going to have diminishing
resources we're going to have economic
crisis what is going to stop the United
States from once again intervening in
the politics of South America to support
its own interests and crushing that hope
which has been outlined tonight thank
you if you get the But microphone just
two rows behind you there was somebody
with a hand up there yeah we'll get the
microphone while that's while the
microphone's reaching we go up to the
top here
yeah uh oh it works um if we think of uh
being a superpow as the exercise of hard
power I'd like to ask the four panel how
a continent could ever be regarded as a
superpow just explain what your doubt is
what you doubt with well what I mean
what by which I mean how can a number of
countries actually directly intervene uh
and exercise power as opposed to uh
America which is obviously one country
and China which is one military under
one command very good thank you we've
got the third one
here no one's mentioned how uh different
political systems might impact the
development of say the Far East or China
in particular compared to South America
I refer to a communist system in the
former and a in general more democratic
system in the latter second and I'd like
to comments from the panel second
question is something that Ferguson in a
talk couple of weeks ago referred to
when he referred to his six killer apps
um that had um explained the dominance
of the West and that one of them was the
Protestant work ethic maybe the panel
might like to comment on how um the
Chinese work ethic and the uh religion
that underpins that um might differ from
the primarily Catholic um work ethic in
South America so two different questions
for the panel are you suggesting uh
people in South America don't work as
hard as not at all I asked the panel to
comment on that very good I just thought
we were straying slightly into Jeremy
Clarkson territory there who um caught
the attention well of course Central
America he was talking about Mexico uh
and and offering a little National
stereotype there but we're not straying
into that territory why did we go with
the um uh first question which I'll put
to the people who are against the motion
first all this one because the other two
I think relate to people who are for the
let's just start with you Bill EMT on
the 60-year history of Latin American
intervention intervention in Latin
America by the United States the
questioner said there's been a long
history of that what's to stop there
being a return to that kind of meddling
let's hear hear you on that and
then uh well um nothing completely but
uh what's uh what's the reason why we
should expect it to intervene um again
in the future the the past history uh
was substantially about the Cold War um
that the United States wasn't the only
outside power seeking to intervene in
the politics of Latin America it was
unfortunately a kind of proxy
Battleground between um the United
States and the Soviet Union during the
Cold War looking into the future uh I
think we could uh ask what's the
interest of of the United States in um
in treading over there they've been
pretty reluctant to take part in the
intervention in Libya they're scarred in
Iraq and
Afghanistan why would even SAR Palin um
intervene in Latin America does Sarah
Palin know where Latin America
is you can't see it from Alaska you you
know what is what is so amazing about
that
please what is so great about that is
that you got to laugh even before you'd
mentioned the joke just by saying her
name you I know that's right let say
something perhaps about London audiences
you get a love just with saying the name
there we let's um put to you uh Oscar
Guardiola Rivera this question about how
can we speak meaningfully about a
superpower um if it's made up of lots of
countries rather than one and
particularly in terms of hard power
military power there obviously isn't one
single military command so how can we
meaning meaningfully speak about a
superpow South
America the uh ambassador of Brazil
already pointed out that uh one of the
advantages of the Americans as a whole
not just Latin America is uh the cult
homogeneity uh as I mentioned one of the
most interesting stories of the next 30
or 40 years is going to be the
hispanization of the United States
nobody's taking that into account this
is the reason why the United States is
not going to intervene in Latin America
in the near
future really we're talking about
demographics where Latinos are where
they are who are they voting for who are
they going to to continue to vote for
which means that the idea that some
saralin might get into office is not as
likely as many people
think the cultural homogeneity of uh
Latin America is strengths
intellectual strengths cultural
strengths mean that for us is much
easier to interact with one another and
as a Unity that it is in any other
region in the world
we Hispanic speakers in Latin America do
not need to learn
Portuguese we speak our portol and
Brazilians understand this they speak
their Portuguese and we understand them
we have a common
history ethnic wise we have plenty in
common I don't know which 13y old is my
friend on the left talking
to I was I was uh I was watching anime
mang anime when I was when I was a kid
but now I asked my uh 10-year-old
daughter who's
English absolutely West country girl and
she listens to
Shakita that sense of
universality that sense of universality
is what allows us to act as a Unity but
most important of all we are changing
the terms of the conversation when it
comes to geopolitics and that's what we
must do geopolitics cannot continue to
be about hard power and War as the norm
of international relations it cannot not
because I I I don't you know I have some
ideal idea of the future but actually
because it is unsustainable the idea
that you can sustain islands of
affluence amidst the oceans of The
Wretched of the Earth by means of force
is completely Bonkers um par do you want
to come in on this particular point I
just want to add one very important uh
additional point to what Oscar said
which is that we're having this
conversation about South America
becoming a superpower despite lacking
those hard power credentials that the
question was about and despite the fact
that that Brazil gave up its nuclear
weapons program over 20 years ago and
yet still you can have a conversation
about how South America is becoming
superow and that really proves Oscar's
point about the new metrics of power
Ambassador why don't you respond to that
and and I'm I also would like you to say
something about the point about the work
ethic of uh people in Brazil and the
wider continent lacking what N Neil
Ferguson called a So-Cal killer app of
the Protestant work ethics say something
about that and then I want to very well
no in relation to the militarization I
think it's very fair to say that today
uh one-sided military intervention is
not as possible as it was 100 years ago
is 100 years ago is worse than it was 50
years ago it's very safe to say that 50
years from now even 20 it's even going
to be more difficult the world is
becoming more balanced and the the fact
that you have individual military power
is no longer as important as it is we're
going to need as I said increased uh
capacity of having horizontal relations
much more than vertical relations which
has pred have predominated over the past
I think this is a very important element
that will create different roles for
different countries and will increase
the visibility and the presence of of
countries that have the preeminence of
being able to dialogue with many other
interlocutors in relation to the work
ethic this is a is a complex issue of
course you can ask whether in Europe you
have the work ethic of the Chinese in
fact the Chinese come to say that we're
not we don't have an undervalued
currency you have underwork people and I
heard the Chinese say that I mean we
work 60 hours a week you work 35 how can
you question our currency this is not
fair uh of in Latin America we work much
more than 35 hours a week of course it
is difficult to balance the cultural
elements involved in this question
I'm not very keen on the Catholic versus
Protestant issue although Latin America
is divided Brazil certainly it's
certainly predominant Catholic but I
think there are different cultural
influences the indigenous influences in
some countries is very important they
contribute to different type of work
ethic but I can tell you very easily
even within Brazil we have this
discussion between people from s Paulo
and Rio de Janeiro and the fact is
that if you want to have fun you go to
Rio if you want to work you go to S
Paulo but the fact is that KOC as I work
very hard as well I'm very glad you said
that R me thank
you R MIT you wanted to come on on the
work ethic question yes briefly well
first of all just uh with all the praise
that's been given to the Chinese work
ethic I am reminded of a restaurant I
visited in China not that long ago when
uh they we waited for ages and ages and
they wouldn't serve us any food when we
asked why they weren't serving they said
well it's dinner time we're busy in
other words with their own meal rather
than than than than anyone else's I
wouldn't for a moment though suggest
that this is is is typical what I think
is really important and this is actually
I think one of these kind of red
herrings the idea that the there is a
sort of religious or ethnic or in some
other way culturally divided way of
understanding work ethic I think misses
the major point which is to do with
economics at the moment the Chinese
government is overly is is worried that
the Chinese people have an overly strong
work ethic because at the moment
basically Chinese people are producing a
very great deal for the export driven
economy and are not consuming near
nearly enough so if as they wish China
is going to have to develop a very
powerful new domestic consumer economy
to keep that growth rate going the
Chinese people are going to have to
learn to play a little bit more and work
a little bit less as well as of course
have more of a a welfare driven system
that enables them actually not to have
to work every hour to make sure that
they've got money to pay for hospital or
educational or uh pension type uh type
bills so in a sense I suspect that one
of the things that we're going to see in
the next 20 years which will add to
China's economic growth is the lessening
rather than the increasing of the work
ethic in the classic sense and a bit
more of a of a consumption ethic just
put put some hands up if we have got
more contributions to come if while
we're waiting for that sorry um Gideon
why did you come in on this yeah just uh
one question that was raised from the
floor and that also in the talks I mean
the big question that people always
raise about China is is uh an unstable
political system uh certainly in America
if you talk about the rise of China the
first thing maybe the second thing
people will say is yeah but it's all
going to blow up isn't it because uh
this is this is not a stable country and
I think they have half a point I don't
think that China has made the political
transition that uh that it that it has
to and I'm sure there is a lot of
instability in store for China uh and
yet I don't think that is um that should
then lead you to the conclusion say oh
well this is kind some kind of Mirage
the Chinese Miracle it certainly isn't
that I mean this is a country that
through chenan Square through the Asian
financial crisis and now the global
financial crisis has continued to grow
pretty fast uh it's had recessions and
so on and even if there is a very
difficult political transition I don't
think it it will mean that China's
suddenly taken off the map
geopolitically not at all I mean to give
you just finish on a a comparison if you
look at Germany uh you know its rise
began in the middle of the 19th century
talk about turbulent they had two world
wars a Great Depression hyperinflation
Etc there's still a major economic power
by
1950 thank you Let's uh take a question
there and we're going to come over here
yeah yeah hi I would like to ask Gideon
rakman in which basis do you argue that
Latin America won't even lead
intellectually and does China has any of
its universities in its top 20 of the
world or do they not have violence Pro
um problems as well thank you uh there's
somebody waiting patiently here Y and
then it'll be you um hi my question or
comment is about a documentary I saw
recently which was focused on Brazil and
in that documentary there are two things
that came out from it and one of them
was showing schools in Brazil I don't
know if they were British American or
Brazilian schools where there were
compulsory um Mandarin lessons which
were taught by teachers um that were
employed by the Chinese government and
living and teaching in Brazil and the
second comment was about how uh local
businesses in Brazil particularly those
that Supply incidentally bikinis were
going out of business because of the
influx of cheap Chinese goods and this
was and in fact that most uh touristic
products in Brazil were actually made in
China so I'd like to invite the panel to
comment on those two things thank you
somebody's oh we've got a couple here
let's if you can be quickly we can get
be quick we can get all of you in and
then get if you can get the microphone
to the church
that be I wanted to ask about ambition
the the US has Manifest Destiny uh the
Chinese think in Millennial terms or the
Middle Kingdom Indians really want a
nuclear bomb um led the non-aligned
Nations um does does Latin America have
the ambition does uh you know I think
not and that's where they're more fun to
have a drink with but uh for the
purposes of the
debate thank you somebody waiting just
behind you yeah um I don't doubt Latin
americ in intentions to become a world
superpower and obviously you mentioned
the US taking them quite seriously in
Obama being there but Cameron's visited
India and China since he's been in power
um Europe is Keen to do business with
China Africa is looking to China for
investment how do you change people's
mentality to encourage them to look West
in order for South America to become the
21st century superpow thank you that's
um very no one else there yes and you I
think it's going to be the last one and
then we're going to bring it back here
Gideon touched on it a second ago um I'm
against the resolution I think the
inevitability of the of the rise of the
East is is um unable momentum however
there's one crack in the dam for me and
that's the potential or even pending
revolution in China as they um arm their
middle classes with higher education and
personal wealth and personal property
I'm surprised the uh the affirmative
side did not explore and use that
argument uh to a greater degree
agree thank you um that's going to be it
for questions what we're going to do now
is move to closing speeches but I'm
going to really urge because they were
really good questions I'm going to urge
our speakers to address some of those
Gideon they were some directed
specifically at you um uh we're going to
do the speeches in um reverse order um
and just while you're working out that
I'll just give you a refresher on uh the
questions asked Gideon you were asked to
well I'll come to that when I come to
you questions for you but most products
in Brazil uh made in China does Latin
America have the ambition to do this
isn't it just reality that Europe and
Africa are all looking to China how do
you persuade them to look otherwise and
isn't China vulnerable because of
pending Revolution and therefore maybe
that gives South America an advantage uh
so we're going in reverse order any of
those you want to address and closing
remarks maximum of really a minute and a
half two minutes
R well let me uh pick up with the very
last point that was made um it's not
hard to find out what's going to happen
with the Chinese middle classes because
they're all around us these days at the
University at which I teach Oxford the
second biggest National group of
students from any country on the
undergraduate level is from China just a
generation ago it would have been the
Republic of Ireland for obvious reasons
geographical proximity now UK is number
one but China number two and I could see
that particularly in theoretical terms
the idea that a growing middle class
will necessarily cause a revolution
particularly because of events in North
Africa is an attractive one but that
isn't so far the overall message that
comes from the Chinese side clearly
they're more politically aware in
various ways but that's a different
thing from arguing there's going to be
an absolute overthrow of the system and
it is probably in that area that the
continuing rise of China as well as of
India and the continuing importance of
Japan and the other powers from the
Asian side make the case for us because
in the last resort we do have here these
blocks which have some sort of
collective identity and as someone has
said in the audience an AS ation
whatever one says about China and India
today it's very clear that they have the
intention of making their weight known
in global Society if you go to India I
was just in India last week on the back
of any scooter or truck or car which is
in front of you in the traffic jam of
which there are many still in in India
there will be a handpainted sign saying
my India is great just next to the sign
saying horn pleas danger so this is
something that clearly sits in the
cultural psyche I am not convinced from
what I've heard heard that that yet
exists on the Latin American side I'm
less convinced that it's going to move
into cyberspace and those other areas
where I think these battles are going to
be fought in one in the next Century
this is not to endorse the rise of China
India or Japan to say it is a good or a
bad thing just as someone has said that
at the moment the weight of the evidence
sits there in the end rather than on the
side of Latin America thank you very
much um two housekeeping points um boxes
are going around now for you to uh vote
it's very obvious if you want to vote
for or against on the slip but if you
are a don't know please put the entire
ticket in The Ballot Box and those
people who are even considering leaving
uh I how can you bear the suspense
you've gotone and wait till 8:30 and you
will find out the result of this vote so
don't even think about it um we are
going to go to our second uh we should
we have a lock in that's uh Gideon Ran's
very Democratic idea to sit you here and
force you to vote and stay for the
result um perhaps he'll be the next
recipient of the Gaddafi prize for human
rights who knows um our second speaker
to sum up is uh Ambassador jaguaribe and
there was a specific question for you
Ambassador I think I've got about Brazil
question you're asking that actually a
lot of the products you see in Brazil
are made in China doesn't that underline
China's strength yes well thank you very
much I think there are many issues
related to the the problem of
competitiveness of Chinese exports and
manufacturers and in the case of Brazil
there's also the big issue of the
overvaluation of the currency uh which
presents an imbalance between our
competitiveness in the commodity
agricultural sector and difficulty with
coping with the valuation of the of our
currency in the industrial sector but
this is a structural this not a
structural issue we can see the German
case which has a continuous history of
valuation of their currency and
maintaining their competitiveness there
are possible alternatives to that but
there's no possible alternative the
question I'm going to put to
you you we can do without bikinis but
nobody can do without eating and eating
is is continuously going to mobilize the
economy of those countries that are be
able are going to be a to be competitive
producers Latin America South America in
particular are continuing to be the most
competitive producers of uh agriculture
in the world uh doing away with the
subsidies that some country utiliz I
think as just as a summarization I
believe that Latin America lacks the
implacability to become and to will a
superpower in the traditional sense of
what the superpower is we don't have the
implacability of the culture that's
associated with superpowers but we have
the ability to bring in impress the
world in different ways which are going
to be increasingly required and they
relate to dialogue they relate to uh
seduction they relate to uh convincing
people other than telling them around
thank you thank you very much offering
thank
you the Ambassador offering a different
modified 21st century definition of what
superpower is and saying on that
definition Latin America will be it uh
our next speaker for to sum up Gideon
rakman the questions that were put
specifically to you was what's your
evidence for suggesting that Latin or
South America can't lead intellectually
and question put was does China have a
university in the global top 20 and what
and surely there's violence in those
places too but you'll have other points
you want to make as well on uh on
leading intellectually now obviously I'm
not suggesting that there there won't be
major intellectual contributions from
Individual Latin Americans and uh and so
on that would be absurd but I don't
think that there is yet for all that
we've heard ideas about the promotion of
social democracy the promotion of
dialogue I don't think there's much of a
sense in the rest of the world that
there is a distinctive Latin American
way that uh that people can emulate or
learn from yet people say you know they
interesting things that's going on in
Brazil followers of social welf reform
are interested in what Lula's done and
so on but there is to be honest no real
Global discussion of a Latin American
Way by contrast I think there is
considerable interest in the Chinese
model people have conscious that there's
an extraordinary story going on there
the Chinese themselves have begun to
pick up this talk of a Beijing consensus
and try to develop it so I think that in
terms of a continent being identified
with a certain way of doing things there
isn't much evidence that that Latin
America is is is getting there yet
certainly by comparison to Asia and in a
more conventional uh intellectual ways
in terms of as you say are are there
Asian universities in the top 20 I'm not
sure about the top 20 certainly in the
top 50 on the other hand uh it is a
Chinese ranking so perhaps perhaps there
would be but so let's take perhaps a
more reliable um statistic numbers of
Engineers uh China is producing and so
is India huge numbers of of Engineers
computer technicians if if you go to
Brazil uh you talk to multinationals
it's the one thing they're very very
concerned about it's hard to find
skilled labor for the moment so I think
that these uh University rankings are
picking up on something that is genuine
and to conclude I think it does all come
back in terms of clout political clout
economic clout to the size of these
economies and the rate at which they're
growing and I read it must be true
because I read it in the economist uh
the CH the Chinese the Chinese economy
is is going to be on current projections
the largest economy in the world by 2019
bigger than that of the United States
the Brazilian economy might be the fifth
largest economy in the world we're not
really talking about the same thing
thank you uh last or next to make his
pitch for your votes which actually
you've already cast um but nevertheless
for the to uh speak for the motion in a
summing up uh fashion Oscar Guardiola
Rivera let me just quote will William
hay November 2010 now is the time for
Britain to At Last to think aresh about
Latin America by any measure Latin
America Matters for example 35% of
global reserves of fresh water and 25%
of the world's cultivable
land 62% of the remaining rainforest in
the world are in Latin America 40% of
global biodiversity is in South America
Latin America is the commodity wool
power house 13% of oil and growing 34%
of copper 59% of coffee 47% of sugar the
sixth larger proven gas reserves in the
world and last but not least because I
hear a lot about the Chinese
model but let me say this today all
South American countries enjoy democracy
and human rights let's leave it at
event thank
you yeah Ju Just Let Me tack on one
question to that because it was a
question came from the floor which is
the notion that even if you're right how
is it you how can you go about
persuading the man mentioned was David
Cameron but also Europe and Africa to
look to Latin America rather than the
questioner said they are at the moment
rightly or wrongly looking to China
just add that on to your remarks well
very modestly you write books about it
such as what if Latin America rul the
world and people like Gideon uh very
kindly recommend them to the readers in
the financial times that's how you
change people's minds let me finish with
this everywhere I go I'm I'm asked okay
what if Latin America ruled the world
and I always half jokingly answer well
we would all dance
better that's how you change people's
minds very nice um our next summer uper
is uh the uh speaking against the motion
Bill
EMT well the first thing I would say is
um that something of the atmosphere of
some of the questions and of the
comments up here on our panel have
suggested that actually it's still all
about us which countries our leaders go
to whether we in intervene in them
whether we will in
invest the fact is that the 21st century
is not all about us it's no longer
something that should or I hope will
revolve all around us it should revolve
around a hell of a lot of countries in
the
world above all I believe it will and I
hope it will revolve an enormous amount
among the part of the world world that
contains more than half of the world's
population namely
Asia the growth and development of Asia
over the past Century but especially uh
since 1945 has been extraordinary and a
wonderful period of human and political
development most important it's been a
period of steady
democratization in
there were no democracies in Asia unless
I've forgotten one now many of the
countries of Asia democracies and they
keep on democratizing bit by bit as
dictatorships move into a more
mature affluent period and
democratization has happened in South
Korea in Taiwan in 1998 in Indonesia in
a way the Asian equivalent of Egypt eypt
where popular overthrow country
dominated by a family led by a military
which was considered the only working
institution in the country became um a
democracy after some troubles after
difficulties but it did become a
democracy so with that background why
would be we be pessimistic about the
prospects in China the prospects in
other Asian countries to develop in the
same way The Experience so far suggests
that they move in a positive
direction Latin America we should
certainly hope we should have great
optimism that Latin America will succeed
will grow will develop but let's be
clear the growth and success of Latin
America is extremely
recent we have something called the
Latin American debt crisis in my first
decade as a journalist
and at that time we would no one would
ever have spoken of Latin America as a
potential future superpower when we look
at Latin America today and we say that
everyone's a democracy we might remember
Cuba we might look at
Venezuela and wonder about the human
rights all over and we might look at the
military saber rattling that's taken
place in recent years between Colombia
and Venezuela and wonder whether we
should be absolutely certain that this
is the continent of peace and of benign
development I hope it will be I hope
that Latin America will succeed but
above all I hope that the world will
progress in a multi-polar way as has
been discussed we shouldn't look West we
shouldn't look East we should look
everywhere thank you thank you very
much thank
you I have in my hand a piece of paper
but before I reveal what's inside it
I'll CL the last word uh and perhaps um
par you might address the question about
whether Latin America has the ambition
to be a superpower that was a question
that came from the floor but a closing
minute from you great well we have made
the case that South America should be
considered a superpower based on its
economy its resources and the fact that
it is peaceful its demographics as well
with an economy that is in fact as large
as China's how could we really rule it
out it's impossible not to take account
all of its latent resources and the fact
that it is through its ambition
beginning to actualize them and in fact
on the question of whether or not or why
the world isn't looking more to Latin
America the fact is that that's exactly
what is happening everyone wants what
Latin America has and that's precisely
what the ambassador's point was most
certainly the US is through the
relocation of Outsourcing so much into
Latin America so the world is looking
very much to to South America today
secondly regime type really matters
normally in geopolitics are very
agnostic about whether a country is a
democracy or a dictatorship but that
doesn't mean that that doesn't matter
because authoritarian regimes are in
fact highly unstable hence the question
from the floor the fact is South America
is largely Democratic and stable and
pres possesses a strong capacity for
social integration the term that that
the Ambassador used meanwhile in Asia
you find a tremendous amount of
demographic instability size demographic
size is not always a blessing if you
look at India and China they both have a
tremendous amount of difficulty for
different reasons in managing such
overwhelming populations and there's
very little evidence to suggest that
they are going to be able to in China's
case grow uh Rich before it grows old
and in India's case to employ such a
large population we cannot ignore the
factor of containment internal and
external in a in the Asian case the
United States is trying very hard to
constrain China's rise and Asian powers
are really hedging against it through
their military uh re uh military uh
expenditures but most of all we should
think not just in terms of continents
but also culture not just about South
America but really the West as a whole
not just the United States and Europe
which together form a true Alliance but
including South America within that in a
real strategic triangle of the West a
collective peaceful superpower
constellation in fact it could very well
be South America's ambition that will
help revive the more abund
West thank you very much thank you
so did the arguments on my right Prevail
or did those on the left Triumph those
just a remind you the vote before the
debate as we came in those for the
motion that yes we should look West not
East uh there were 236 for
279 against and 201 don't knows I can
tell you the don't knows have now gone
down from 2011 to 49 so where did those
150 go those four for the motion that
yes we should look West not East South
South America will be the 21st century
superpower
204 those against it
447 so the motion has been soundly
defeated hold on I'm sure you're going
to want to as we lick our wounds those
who've been defeated I'm sure you're
going to want to join me in thanking our
Stellar lineup of speakers Oscar gel
Rivera Roberto Jag B gide rman R thank
you all very
[Applause]
much